let us not underestimate the
terrible consequences of this absence of
fundamental reforms for the peoples of europe
greece is a particularly painful example of
this but it is osk a and deplores
madness to attract to the fox is a meeting
in greece and make offers to the
whims of opinion analysts of 4 at
the fcpe meeting maternity wards meeting
of a number of country its bar of 1.20
us mystique of a strict group is
progressing now yes with the number
of processes
it will make $10 at tv mag too
wanted commissions is true nothing of
ad leggings elsewhere romans called from the
stam stirs up all crimes to our taste
cried brazilian smoothies cries
said the guide the distance of arms to 10
world to this traffic to the rebound of the cac
loses we are  robbed range means